i think what a lot of people don't know
about panda is that we're a family
business
and i think the unique role that panda
plays
is that we were the first taste of
chinese food for many in the u.s
what i say about panda is we are the
largest mom and pop chinese restaurant
in the world
and our cause has everything to do with
being american chinese
and everything to do with creating
opportunities for people
[Music]
well i was born in china and i grew up
in taiwan
and spent about four and a half years in
japan
before i came to united states i was
born in
burma raised in hong kong and
came over here for college education my
husband
after graduate he came over to
california
to open the restaurant with his father
so panda inn was built in 1973
when we first started the restaurant
business
i thought it would be a lot easier to
make money
oh no it wasn't like that the first
month
we did like twelve thousand dollars that
was like 400 bucks a day
you know i used to make a couple hundred
dollars
just as a waiter my father was front of
the house and greeting guests
my grandfather was back of the house and
he was making food for the guests
my mom who was already an electrical
engineer
would come and be a hostess on the
weekend and there was my grandmother and
my uncles and my aunties and they'd all
come together to really support this
family business
so in terms of growing up as part of
this panda business what i knew about
business was that business was going to
be about
family because of panda inn we got
invited
by the developer of glendale galleria
to go and open a restaurant
in the mall and that is
when i really start to look at the
possibilities
because small is actually a new thing at
that point
of time we do our very best how to
provide
the food that we have we really have to
focus on
great food great service and we are beer
i took what we serve from pandian
and simplified it and made it work
at the pan express i remember when we
started
we have the longest line i would say
longer than most other restaurants
i find it oh wow this is quite good
it was easier to do and i went all the
place
to open restaurants
my parents have done this incredible job
they came to the us with nothing and
they were able to build a business
that's now a household name but when it
comes to the second generation what does
that mean
what does it mean to honor the legacy
the foundation that they've built
but also what does stewardship look like
for the second generation
many of us that embody this duality and
ethnic identity
when we were growing up maybe it was
being a little apologetic
for the ethnic sides of our identity and
we at panda are saying hey no we are
unapologetically american chinese so
that the next generation
coming up can say not only are they not
apologetic and unapologetically american
chinese
but they are celebrating their ethnic
identity i think what's really important
to recognize
is that anti-asian hate isn't new
because of appearance
because of fear asian americans aapis
may be labeled as forever foreigners
and then it begs the question well if
systemic racism
exists what is the role that we can play
what can panda do
and that's where we launch the panda
community fund
and it is a five-year commitment of 10
million dollars
and likely to continue but really what
it is is looking into our communities
identifying this local and those
national programs the people that are
already doing
fantastic work to help the victims of
racism and violence
to help those that are already
amplifying and educating people about
the beauty and diversity of the u.s
and supporting them in their work
american dream is really defined by
individuals differently and
for me it's actually that you content
with what you have and and also able to
make a
you know a good citizen in the community
i think being the beneficiary
of united states and being educated here
people in the chinese community or maybe
asian community we all
know that we have to give him back as a
second generation as we look to the
third generation
i think what it means is if we're moving
from
survival and stability to a level of
stewardship
and celebration the american dream means
how can we have the freedom to honor the
past
and honor origin but also have the
freedom for original expression
only in america you know you get to do
this
and also i think i'm very proud
that we did it right you know we work
with our people we took good care of our
people
you know we make sure that
in our ability that they grew
our job really is continue to
figure out ways that our people can
prosper
how do we pay them more how do we
make the work easier
and more functional and you know how do
we get people to come back
frequently over and over again so do
every little thing
do them exceptionally well it really is
about modeling
we don't manage people we lead them
we lead them by setting an example this
is how
you could do like i have done when
our people grow our business world